hello everybody
this is anshumanik i hope that
all of you can hear me well
i think it's about time so we can get
started
so this talk is going to be about some
interesting projects
and prototypes and inspired concepts
what that means is that we have actually
worked on some very interesting projects
coming from our clients
as well as some concepts for them and
i would like to share some of those of
course
one of the constraints that we face is
that we can't talk about the projects
directly you know using the same topic
because of the non-disclosure agreements
that we have generally with pretty much
all of our
customers and clients in technical
consulting
uh but then what i have tried to do is
to show you the projects which are going
to be as close conceptually to those
and the second disclaimer of course also
is that therefore
but i'll show you some of the prototypes
those are actually prototypes
not actual production system production
environment systems as such
but that should actually present the
concept that
i wanted to share with all of you of
course
let me first begin with
what does the technical consulting team
do i think
many of you may be aware of what our
team does but some of you may not be
so in the interest for in the interest
of those
participants i'm going to present it
very very quickly first of all
some of you may have been more familiar
with the name technical services
now that has been changed to technical
consulting so
i hope that that doesn't create any
confusion it's the same team but
we are now technical consulting group so
we have always tried to make our
offerings
you know our services as flexible as
possible for our
clients however we have tried to
categorize
in what ways we can engage with them so
the first
primary way could have been project
support where we
take the requirements data
specifications from you
we go ahead and design develop and
deploy it for you so that's like turnkey
project
or we be engaged in you know under
what's called as
development support in this offering we
work as collaborately with you as an
extension of your team
like any other team member whatever work
that you would like us to be able to
uh do for you we can do that business
support on the other hand
is where our constituents work full time
with you on
any broad variety of projects that you
may be working on
they're exclusively there for you we
also provide advanced training
which are customized to the specific
projects that you may be working on
and application support for any
application that you have developed
or may have developed for you so this is
just to give you an idea what are the
engagements that consulting team has
that's not really the topic of the
discussion today
but i did want to impress on this fact
that
because wolfram language it has such a
broad base
so we tend to get projects from pretty
much
all different verticals of course as you
can see in this chart
uh you know companies from engineering
and technology background
vertigo tend to be the larger
you know tend to be the larger fraction
of the
projects uh but then we get good
knowledge projects from finance and
banking government
and are very representational factions
from education media energy and so on
and there's something that keeps our
team very excited
now one of the reasons why i mentioned
this is that obviously we will not be
able to talk about
you know all different things that can
be done so
i have picked up a few projects and
concepts for
discussion today so first is natural
language query for your data
second the concept of decision support
system i'll go into more details when we
get there
and then we developed our own custom
online learning system we'll then talk
about
about fault detection using machine
learning
and finally about targeted marketing
using machine learning
so let me get started with the natural
language query so
most of you must be familiar with word
from alpha
which answers questions in plain english
however
from alpha has its own data and you're
creating into that data set only
but what if you have your own data then
we can actually apply the same concepts
the same functionality invoking
language to your data and i'm going to
show
just a few examples so
in this case i'm going to be talking
about a factory outlet data i have
gathered just
you know i think a few months worth of
data in this case for demonstration
so let me just ask using plain
english so let's say sales
after march 21st
and i'm going to say search
now what it is doing is it's actually
looking into the database
it fetched the data filtered it then
developed these statistics and
visualizations and return it back to us
so the entire process you know got
shortened to like two or three seconds
that it took
but then we can see some very
interesting results that come out of it
just with a simple search that we
did for example there were 93 sales
and the mean of the sale happens to be
around 300
standard deviation itself is more than
200 so i think the spread
seems to be somewhat appreciable then
the minimum is at 19 whereas the maximum
is at 900
so it's i think it's like a very thin
tail on the right side but a fat tail on
the left side
so i can derive that kind of you know
intelligence right away
but we can look at how the sales have
actually grown over a period of time
in this case i chose to have only about
you know 10 days worth of data
for this query now some more interesting
things come here
uh this shows that you know maximum
number of sales have happened
for the lower price range products
and very few for the higher ones which
probably is expected
now because in this particular query i
asked about sales which you know relates
to revenue
so it's giving me option only for
revenue but if there were queries where
multiple factors could have been
involved
then i would actually automatically get
a drop down to be able to
see the rest of transfer all of all of
them now here is something which is
even more interesting because now it is
showing us
geo especially what that sale has been
and we can see that well pretty much all
the suburbs around chicago in this case
uh they have contributed well enough to
sales certain ones like when they're not
broke
seems to have contributed more than
others
so this gives you a very good feel for
how the sales has been happening right
it could be other types of
visualizations it could be for
let's say larger regions it need not be
just around the city it could be entire
u.s
or it could be the entire you know north
america or entire
planet for that matter but then it gives
you very good feed for it and remember
that all of this is coming just with
you know four or five word sets that we
did
here we can derive actually even more
inside this is the distribution of the
sales
we can see that this is you know fat
right around the
bottom dollar values but at the top
dollar values it tapers off
but here is something which really
excites me
as a user it actually went ahead and run
ran an anova analysis for me and it
tells me that in this case
you know it is plotting branches a b c
for the corresponding data and it tells
me that
sigma you know the the difference
between
these three branches are not that
significant
um in fact if i go to let's say product
line distributions are different
in this case you know but but i can
still see that the p
values happens to be much lower than
0.05
so in certain data sets i think it could
be that the differences are significant
and it even gives me
the the conclusion from this
statistical analysis now this is just
you know a few of the results that
we have put in for a prototype however
it could be
many more pretty much any types of
results that you'll be interested in
seeing
now let's see if there are other types
of data
let's say
electronic accessories
uh maybe rating rather than sales
so now it is going to look into another
table
it tells me that you know there are 170
ratings for
electronic accessories what the
corresponding rating values have been
what the distribution is
then again what the geospatial
distribution is and
what the statistical distribution is for
that and then i could be looking at
other parameters also for this so
the idea is that just using
natural language queries so much can be
derived so much of intelligence
can be derived i could actually run
several others but because we have only
20 minutes in total so i'm going to
go over to the next slide
for next example now
we are talking about decision support
systems it's not like a product
but let's think about what are the types
of tools that
if we had in hand we could make our
decisions much more quickly it would
have been very informed decision
but also quicker so if a tool could
actually
achieve the goal of having high quality
data integration date and then data
aggregation so that we can look at
different levels of the data
have very quick analysis tools you know
at our fingertips
and then also connect that to a
knowledge base not just
the intelligence that's inherent in the
data but connect that that to the real
world data for example
uh let's say weather data sales will be
affected by weather data or let's say
population data what type of population
is there around
you know let's say that particular
factory output from the previous example
and so on
and then if we can simplify the process
of data access itself so that we can
look at different views very quickly
use nlp to query into them then that
definitely will help us shorten the
decision making process
now even more important than is hey what
are the things that will actually help
us make the right decision in terms of
you know the insights that are required
the
predictions that we may need to see or
the cause and effect that we may want to
learn about
what are the things what are the factors
and what types of effects they have had
so multi-domain visualization will help
a lot with this and we have hundreds of
them
that you know they're all available on
the same platform uh monitoring trends
doing comparisons you know deriving
cause and effect relationship
using modeling that could be suicidal
modeling or machine learning modeling
and whatnot
geospatial analysis and so on um
even you know time series forecasting
report generation
then these actually will help us make
better decisions
it strengthens the process so but then
is it going to be like a bunch of tools
all strewn over
you know an entire area now it could be
very integrated
so here is a prototype to show that
so it could have its own dashboard which
is showing the elements that you are
interested in it need not be
you know like a pre-packaged dashboard
um
so we are looking at let's say revenue
data we just created some synthetic
this is showing me how we have done over
different years
it's again showing me geospatially how
we performed
and even forecasting so now this these
are
selected group of things that you want
to put in a dashboard that you want to
be monitoring
it could be other things as well but
then what if i want to dive deeper into
the data set itself
then we could do that let's say in the
same interface
but then we can do it very very easily
so what
what i really want to highlight is that
is the ease of things and the integrated
nature of
it so revenue let's say if i
want to get quarterly revenue apply
changes
that shows me quite a bit of no i want
to change let's say the timeline that's
2018 let me go back to
2016 that fetches me data for all of
that
then i could be looking at groupings of
the revenue based on let's say the
salesperson
or uh grouping of numbers
or you know how we have done in terms of
billable hours it could be other factors
but then so far what we have shown seems
to be more or less like data fetching
it can go much farther than that here
you see there is computation going on
so given all the data there may be a
certain definition of efficiency for you
and the system would actually use that
definition
and provide you with results literally
on the fly
or the way that you calculate your
returns it could be
simple net profit returns a ratio or it
could be your own formula
with all integrated in the same platform
now
let's talk about looking at the trends
uh superposing different components so
let's say
what are the types of sales amounts of
sales coming from return customers
compared with you know our sales team
actually working on it
and there can be some many other
resources as well right
so this gives me you know much more
insight
about what may be happening now we go
step forward
and we say hey i want to see how we are
expected to do in next
few months or let's go to next six
months apply changes and it came back
with
six months worth of forecast so this
tells me in this particular case
hey there's going to be a downturn
so this is probably the right time to
to to bring about those changes which
can
arrest that downturn right because we
know in advance
that if we maintain status quo we may be
losing revenue
so this already gives me sort of a flag
and of course you know other types of
visualizations that can be added to this
i talked about heat map in the in the
dashboard itself now you see i can
generate heat map based on all these
different factors so based on project
types we have four here
our source of the revenue verticals or
sales rep and so on
and so on again if you want to filter
the data
totally customized way which means i
want to see some very very specific
things
we have pretty much all the factors that
are there in the data
you know present here choosing any of
these and selecting for
you know any sets of them i can get
my views for the data so let's supply
changes
that's the filter applied on that now
all of these are there but then
if i want to generate a report let's say
for this view it could be something as
simple as
add to report that i clicked here let me
add a few
more so let's say this one
and we're going to include these add to
report
let's say another chart
now you see what happens if i go to the
report module
the ones that i selected they're showing
up here that i want these in the report
now generating the report can be as
simple as clicking on this button
and i get those results already in the
form for a report
with their sections and whatnot now here
in fact even interactivity is involved
so
what these are exactly the numbers we
saw for return customers
and other different sources right so
this is interesting because all of
the different things that we talked in
terms of decision support system
has got coil-less or integrated into
one product and of course there could be
no other views as well
and we could have nlp also working right
here
so let's say revenue i'm just going to
quickly try one of these
and the same data and visualization that
we got there
or even more could be derived using the
energy search as well
so this tells you that we
we have an integrator you know we could
develop an integrated platform to do all
of that and you know other types of
modules that
we may want to add by the way i should
have mentioned that this is all
happening in our notebook
we just built it in this way so it's
like any other application that you
would use
okay so let's move on to the next
example here
as i said we developed an online
learning system
i'm going to brief through this rather
quickly but the idea was
that in this case you know minnesota
university of minnesota
wanted to have their own learning system
where they'll have full control over
things you know
permissions for different groups of
people accessing it
the way that homeworks are put in the
question bank there should be their own
question bank
and the way that students should answer
their questions there should be control
over it for example
if a mass professor wants them to uh
reply to questions in the form of
fractions or three over two rather than
giving
a decimal number then they can apply
those
then this system actually allows for all
of that
and then if you can see in this case
they can the faculty can
create questions whether you know like
single question or multiple choice
questions or multi-card questions
and even include other components like
graphics or mathematical expressions or
even manipulate i think most of you may
have may have heard of manipulate
so that can become part of the question
paper itself
now whatever they create here using this
notebook which can be used offline which
is very very handy because one could be
taking several hours or so
one could be working on it for several
days you save it as a file continue
working on it
and when you want to publish it then you
can combine those questions from the
notebook
with the questions which are there in
the question bank because now these
questions from the notebook also will go
into the question bank
and you can pick and choose from any
sources the question bank itself the
previous semester exams or quizzes and
whatnot
and be able to come up with your
homework assignment within a matter of
minutes
and then to go from that assignment to
publishing it which becomes available to
the students
is literally click of a button it takes
about a few seconds
and students that actually have access
to those uh
tests and quizzes and whatnot then here
there are other features like you know
being able to put in
uh being able to see the traditional
form of the expression they are putting
in
so that they can ensure they are putting
it right the system also auto grades and
as most of you may know mathematica
obviously
from language has very powerful
mathematical engine so it's not about
just
matching answers it's about
equivalencies of answers and it actually
caters to that it allows for
tolerances one student man said 3.35
another man's a 3.4
it can understand the professor can set
those tolerances and whatnot so
all kinds of controls that they wanted
to have and because of these
now this system has been running there
for six years i think more than six
years
thousands and thousands of students are
taking tests using the system
but let me show you another dimension to
it rather quickly
we can be looking at very interesting
you know insights from the data
collected from the system
so let's say these are the distribution
of the marks and semester one for a
particular class
how have they performed over different
semesters and as you can see the
performance seems to have
broadened which means the students are
you know
performing very differently from each
other which is much more close packed
initially so this probably tells me a
story that probably some kind of
improvement is required in which in
which way that teaching
is being done and we can look at the
individual data or different
visualizations like this is the
trajectory of a particular student
compared to the entire population of his
class
and we can see his performance have been
wobbling so maybe that student
needs help so all kinds of insights that
can be derived from this kind of
analysis
and this is all integrated in the form
of an online learning system
so let me move to the second last
example
uh here we have a printed circuit board
we can
actually use machine learning to detect
what are the different components or
where those components are
get the bounding boxes using machine
learning or you know
standard convolutional network
convolution convolution new network and
then
get automatically the cropped images of
those components
compare that to the library that the
system may already have
and then create a digital
view of the circuit board now that can
be compared to the original design
and you know if there are false
components are not in the right place so
right
kinds of components are not there or you
know their ratings are different they
can be detected more or less
automatically using the mule framework
that virtual language has
now similarly let's imagine that a drone
is flown over an entire region
over several days data is collected for
all the
rules that are there now machine
learning can be used
to to classify them into the materials
used for different roofs now suddenly
you have an entire mapping of
of the market let's say it's a roofing
company then they know what the market
is like
how many houses are using you know metal
roofs versus wood and
and so on and they can target much
better in addition to that we can go
next step
and identify which are the houses which
require repair or require maybe
replacement altogether
so now the company can market it in very
very specific ways to those specific
customers
giving them you know they're just the
right types of options that
you think is going to be most most
advantageous for them
again using the cnns so of course
you know given the limited time we had i
presented it at a high level
but if you have any questions we could
take them i think we
do have a few minutes left
okay so i'll see if somebody is
posing a question but i just wanted to
show that you know the unique features
of the consulting group brings to the
table you know multi-paradigm approach
to the problems that we try to
attack and solve the domain expertise
that our team has
and you know people with computational
expertise as well as
expertise in you know from technologies
uh people who can work cross discipline
having very innovative ways of using
reference technologies and so on
so i would encourage you know all of you
if you do have project ideas in mind and
you know
if you if you want to have a sounding
board you want to have
a team who can help you get to the next
level then
please don't hesitate and come and talk
to us
we are excited to see the amazing
projects that our customers have been
doing
in fact pretty much everything that i
showed today they are inspired by
real life projects you know that our
team has been doing
and that's what actually keeps us so
excited
okay
any questions from anybody
i hope i'm not missing the questions
maybe somebody's trying to ask
oh yeah yeah there are some raised hands
here
okay
yes michael you had a question
oops are the controls working all right
okay can you hear me yeah i can't be
good okay
um yes uh there was a couple questions
in the chat section um people are asking
to what extent
the um the decision support system is
different from what you can get in
tableau
[Music]
oh it's very good question
so the difference is in two ways
see tableau comes with pre-packaged
options and
solutions and you can use them and
that's very effective at that level
and kudos to the team for doing it well
what we bring to the table is all custom
ways of looking at things
not things which are pre-packaged and
then things which are specific to your
business
things which are most interesting to you
and
deeper level analyses in fact i didn't
have time to talk about it but
for example if you're working on sales
then using that data
to actually develop simulations to be
able to run let's say what a scenario so
let's say if it's you know going back to
my example of
factory outlet what if scenarios what if
i
change my pricing this way what if i
open another store
in a certain location and some
malaysians can actually return those
results
so the dss could have a framework for
the simulations
and we could generate those insights
using that that is just one example
there can be very you know interesting
views that you want to
create from the scratch and dss can
support that
in addition to that let's say tomorrow
if you want to add a custom module to it
then this allows for that right so there
are so many different ways in which you
can customize it
and you can you know you can get it
developed specifically for you rather
than
adapting yourself for an existing uh you
know product or a set of tools
yeah the the google data studio
also allows for um you know future
projections
is um so how do we differ from that
right that's a good question so
we can differ because see there are
automated ways of forecasting like we
did in this case
what if we want to force the a specific
type of model
you know let's say time series model or
imax model
then you don't really get control like
that
with you know several other systems but
we can actually integrate that
into the dss itself right so it could be
specific types of lmx modeling which has
been more effective for
your business they get integra
integrated into the dss and you use them
and there can be different options it
need not be just one particular
type of forecasting and so on so all of
this
and as i said at any point the
functionality can be extended
based on the latest and greater things
that are coming out in working language
and as you know we have been
very very aggressive in developing new
functionality
so they can be you know continuously
added to enrich
the dss that you may have for yourself
okay thanks very much andrew yeah
welcome
okay so i think uh we're
on the dot in terms of time i i can wait
for a few more minutes if
anybody else had questions
of course let me mention in the
meanwhile that if you
if you would like to meet the consulting
group there is
a booth that you can go from the
products and demos
uh menus from pathable uh
main page and there are our developers
who are available there from 9am to 2pm
central time and you can interact with
them
i'm also there you know for a bit of
that
bit of the time and you can ask for
meetings as well
okay so i do have something coming in
the chat
if you would like to contact us uh the
question is
is there an email address yeah you can
write to
tech inquiries at wolfram.com
so let's say
so that's tech inquiries at wolfram.com
or our number which is two one seven
uh zero nine eight
seven one eight one ah
three nine x
so you can you can talk to us as well of
course as you are
in the conference we are available in
pathable
so we definitely can be available
through meetings
as well okay
so i think we'll stop here thank you
very much for
for attending the talk and looking
forward to seeing some of you
in other talks as well as on the booth
thank you
you